lord haywood good morning to you and
thank you for being with us so good
morning
first of all you do think this trust is
going to win this i do yes
and why do you not think you'll be as
emphatic as some of the polls suggest
all the indications which have come from
both conservative party contacts
and also in
from journalists who've attended the
hustings is that actually
richie has had more support than the
polls would suggest i've had some
discussions with polling companies about
their possible uh margin for error
because they were concerned about
hearing the same sorts of messages but i
think the overall message i've got from
friends from conservative party members
mps uh is that it will be a trust
victory
uh lord haywood what kind of a margin of
victory do you think we could see
i don't know because we don't even know
what level of turnout we've got um
people
amazingly enough don't return their
ballot papers even when they've got
postal votes
at general elections and i think the
same now so it would be very difficult
to speculate there's been ebbs and flows
there's been a sense that rishi has done
better later on in the campaign but we
don't know how many people had actually
retained their ballot papers until the
the latter days so i i'm really not
willing to make a projection
fair enough i thought it was a bit of a
cheeky question
let me put it to you this way then i
mean there is a lot of discussion about
the division within the conservative
party um and if it's not a huge
overwhelming win for this trust i mean
that division will still be there and it
will perhaps fester
it will
but i think the important thing for this
trust
is not only to deal with the emergencies
which are facing the nation's economy
particularly but also setting about
healing the wounds within the party by
bringing in
leading supporters of the rishi campaign
into her cabinet i heard david davis
yesterday on soviet ridge making exactly
the same point
that you can't govern properly unless
you have a united governing party and
that to govern you're going to have to
bring in some key risky supporters at a
high level
in government
yeah i mean all you guys are saying is
all the grandes are saying that it needs
to be a a cabinet that reflects the
breadth of the party but we've seen the
reporting of who is likely to be in
those top jobs and that doesn't reflect
the breadth of the party at all no it
doesn't and that's something that
concerns me uh now
i'm sure that uh liz trust has heard the
messages coming from whoever it may
happen to be
and i think there is
a general assessment that boris's first
cabinet was a bad cabinet because all he
did was award uh his friends jobs of
people who were absolute loyalists
and that doesn't work if you go back to
mrs thatcher's stage when she became
prime minister she brought all sorts of
people who were known to be critics of
hers into cabinet
and that's how you set about reuniting
the party because it has to be reunited
at the top
and work downwards from there
and this goes to the heart of how eliza
trust government would be run wouldn't
it because who she puts in place at the
very beginning is going to set out as to
how she's going to govern
and if she doesn't set in place a team
that as you say that has all the sort of
talents and there's a broad sort of uh
base of ideas she's gonna really
struggle there's already reporting that
some people are already planning a coup
to ouster
um
yes i i think that's improbable i think
that's just uh fanciful gossip and
bar room chat um the the key thing as
far as liz trusts and her supporters are
concerned are very it's very clear that
she's got to
get in get a move on in terms of forming
a government and at the same time
very very quickly in the next few days
deal with the the cost of living and
energy issues that are
really pounding as you've just been
hearing both
the
the
individuals but also uh the commercial
and industrial sectors
and a quick thought from you then lord
haywood on a couple of those things uh
first of all on the reporting this
morning about the huge numbers that have
been uh suggested as part of that cost
living package some 100 billion and a
price cap coming in i mean how did you
react when you when you read that
reporting that that might be an idea
it's headlines it's headlines and one
never knows what goes
with those things in one form or another
so clearly the treasury civil servants
will have been working incredibly hard
over the last few weeks preparing briefs
dealing with the current chancellor and
um
they will have to look at the issue in
detail rather than dealing with
broadline space uh speculation i'm
afraid
okay and i thought then on the process
there's been two months of this we're
going to finally find out in a couple of
hours time uh who is the leader i mean
it's gone on way too long hasn't it yes
it has
and uh we have had this hiatus as far as
i'm concerned
we shouldn't have had this hiatus in
this form with a temporary new
government with boris johnson still in
uh in premiership uh the rules that we
have were adopted if we were in
opposition uh and we now need to look at
whether we change the rules if we're in
government
uh lord hayward finally then i mean you
wouldn't speculate on what the margin of
victory would be i wonder if you'll
indulge me on this i mean you've seen a
lot of prime ministers over the years
excuse me who was the best prime
minister and why
um i think there's no doubt that mrs
thatcher was the best prime minister she
didn't face the size of in tray that liz
truss is likely to face but she had
massive structural problems in this
country and she tackled a lot of them
okay lord robert always good to get your
thoughts sir thank you so much thank you